Okay, so again, very exciting topic which I'm
excited to teach about, which is the Yom
Tov tourist, if anyone in this room or
anyone listening might end up in Israel, so
the big question is going to be, not
just Pesach but Shavuos and Succos and Succos,
how many days of Yom Tov are you
keeping? And this is a very, very relevant
question, you know, really all the time it
comes up every single chag, people are asked,
people are asking, people hear something from their
friend. So let's learn the sources together. I'm
going to put a disclaimer right now that
I am not going to be giving, you
know, the official psak, but I will kind
of just let you know what's out there
a little bit. I'll tell you if there
are official psakim, but for the most part,
we're just kind of learning the sugya over
here. Okay, so the starting point with this
sugya, you really have to just we need
a little bit of background. Right, so originally,
originally, before we had a fixed calendar, right
now our calendar is fixed. If you look
on the Ezras Torah luach, you'll figure out
exactly how long each month is, and when
the molad etc. All this stuff is you
can figure out from Google, from your luach.
Way back when it didn't work that way.
Way back when the way it worked al
pi din Torah, they would have two edim
come, two edim would see the new moon,
and if edim saw the new moon, so
they would come to the Beis Din HaGadol,
the Beis Din HaGadol based on their testimony
would say, okay, the new moon has come,
which means that it is a brand new
month, and based on the testimony, or lack
thereof, they would decide that the previous month
had either been 29 days or had been
30 days. But you, if you weren't, you
know, around, if you didn't have basically no
then there was impossible for you to know
how long the previous month was going to
be. So let's say it was Pesach coming
up, so and you lived very, very far
away. So you don't know, is today the
first day of Nissan already? Or are we
on the last day of Adar Sheini? You
wouldn't know, you wouldn't have an idea. So
now, once they figure that out, they then
have to send shluchim, they have to go
and send people across all of Eretz Yisrael
and outside of Eretz Yisrael, tell all the
Jewish communities, hey, look, you know, we made
it X amount of days or we made
it Y amount of days, the month was
either malei or it was chaser. So the
way it worked out is that practically if
people were outside of a certain distance, if
people were outside of let's say a fifteen
days' travel so that they wouldn't have heard
whether which way Nissan worked, which way Nissan
or really the previous month, which way Adar
how long it was, so they would end
up having to keep two days of Pesach
because they weren't sure is today the first
day of Pesach, is it the last day
before Pesach etc. and automatically you'd end up
keeping two days of Yom Tov. So that
makes all a lot of sense. Everything changed
once they once they made a fixed calendar.
Because now that we have a fixed calendar,
again you can look at your Ezras Torah
luach, you can see exactly how long is
this month and how long is the next
month, so I know with certainty that the
15th of Nissan is the 15th of Nissan.
So why do I have to go and
keep two days? I know the only in
the Torah the only there's only one day
of Yom Tov at the beginning of Pesach,
there's only one day of Yom Tov at
the end of Pesach, I should only have
to keep one day, why do I have
to keep more than that? So the Gemara
in Beitzah addresses all this. It first tells
us the background, Barishona in source one, hayu
masi'in masu'os. So they used to, this is
Barishona Barishona, a quicker way to get the
information out. Originally what they would do instead
of actually sending runners to go and tell
people, hey, you know, we made the chodesh
a certain way, is they would light bonfires.
The bonfires would tell would be a signal
for how long the month was and that
was a much more efficient system. You could
go from mountain to mountain to mountain and
spread word very, very fast all in the
course of one night. However, mishekilkelu haKusim, then
the Kusim came along, the Samaritans, they made
trouble for the rabbinic Jews and they wanted
to mess with our calendar. So they would
go ahead and light the bonfires when we
weren't supposed to light the bonfires and they
threw the entire calendar into whack. So they
had to stop doing this whole fire lighting
thing. hiskinu sheyehu shluchim yotzin. They said, okay,
so we have to go and send shluchim,
fine. v'ilu batlu Kutim avidnan chad yoma, okay
etc. I'm going to just skip to the
next line, v'hashta d'yad'inan b'kvi'a d'yarcha, but nowadays
that we actually know exactly when the calendar
how long it is, that happened around the
4th century CE when the calendar was set
by Hillel HaSheini, so mai ta'ama avidnan try
yomei. So why do we do two days
nowadays? And the answer is mishum d'shalchu m'tam
because it was sent from there. Ironically, shalchu
m'tam means it was sent from Eretz Yisrael.
So the people who were sending this psak
were from Eretz Yisrael. I think the Gemara
in Sanhedrin says it might be Rabbi Eliezer,
one of the Tannaim or Amoraim there in
in Israel, hizaharu b'minhag avoteichem b'yadeichem. You have
to be careful about the minhag of your
fathers in your hands, keep the minhagim of
your of your parents. Your parents used to
keep two days outside of Eretz Yisrael, so
you too also keep two days of Yom
Tov outside of Eretz Yisrael. zimnin d'gazru shmad
v'ati l'kilkulei. Why do you have to keep
the minhag? Because what's going to happen? Maybe
one day there's going to be a shmad,
there's going to be they're going to prevent
the Jews from keeping Torah properly, they're going
to prevent people from learning Torah properly and
you're not going to be able to figure
out exactly when is how long is the
month. Right, meaning let's say they got rid
of all the Ezras Torah luchos, so how
would you know how long... The luach is.
So there's all these calculations, there's a whole
siman in Shulchan Aruch about how to figure
out how the calendar works. It's not so
simple. I'm seeing Davida has... What? You call
up Sam. Right. So Sam knows it. So
Rav Moshe Feinstein, this might seem like a
little crazy, like, are we really worried about
a shmad and people aren't going to know
how to calculate? So Rav Moshe Feinstein, he
lived in Luban in Russia and he was
under the communist regime, they were attacking Judaism
as a whole, they were trying to get
us to stop learning Torah. So Rav Moshe
was basically kicked out of Russia and his
last act before he left Russia was to
write out the next couple decades of the
Hebrew calendar because he knew that no one
in Luban would have any clue what the
calendar was going to look like without him.
That was his last act. So you can
see if you weren't in Rav Moshe's Luban,
I don't know what the other areas did,
but people really there wasn't such a clear
way of knowing the calendar. Now it's true
we have Google, so Google kind of changes
things, but it's not like it's such a
far-fetched takkanah that we keep two days of
Yom Tov. Okay, so that's the background to
why we keep two days of Yom Tov
in Chutz La'aretz. The question now becomes: okay,
so I'm a Ben Chutz La'aretz. I'm going
to use that term sometimes, Ben Chutz La'aretz,
someone from Chutz La'aretz, maybe I'll just say
an American, that's a little simpler. I'm an
American. I come to Israel. So in Israel
they keep one day, this takkanah was never
ever created that you have to keep two
days of Yom Tov. In Chutz La'aretz there's
a takkanah that Americans and other Bnei Chutz
La'aretz have to keep two days of Yom
Tov. So what do you do then? That's
the big question. So if the, I guess
the starting point is that it seems like
it's not so complicated. It seems like if
you learn one Gemara the answer should be
pretty straightforward. The Gemara goes as follows: this
Gemara in the fourth perek of Pesachim, it's
a Mishnah really. It says makom shenahagu la'asot
melacha be'arvei Pesachim ad chatzot osin. If you
have a place, this is not talking about
Yom Tov, it's talking about a minhag which
some had not to do any melacha on
the day on Erev Pesach in the morning
before Pesach actually started. So it's talking about
minhagim in general. But makom shenahagu la'asot melacha
be'arvei Pesachim ad chatzot osin. If you have
a minhag to go and do melacha Erev
Pesach up until chatzot, no problem. makom shenahagu
shelo la'asot ein osin. But if you're in
a place which has a minhag not to
go and do melacha on Erev Pesach, so
you should join that minhag and you should
not be doing... you're part of those people
so you should not be doing melacha. What
if I'm a traveler? haholech mimakom she'osin lemakom
she'ein osin. Let's say I am going from
a place where they do melacha to a
place where they don't do melacha. o mimakom
she'ein osin lemakom she'osin, or I'm doing the
reverse, I'm going from a place where they
don't do melacha and I'm coming to a
place where they do do melacha. So what's
the halacha? The halacha is notnin alav chumrei
makom sheyatza misham vechumrei makom shehalach lesham. The
rule is that you give the chumros of
both places on the person. So if you
were machmir over there you have to still
be machmir, if they're machmir over here you
have to still be machmir. If that's all
you had, and ve'al yeshaneh adam mipnei hamachlokes.
And don't change anything because of machlokes, meaning
don't do differently than where you're at because
of machlokes. So if I only had that
Mishnah before I saw the Rishonim, so it
would sound like okay I just have to
be machmir in all directions. So what would
being machmir in all directions even look like
in Israel? Let's say I get creative... ve'al
yeshaneh adam mipnei hamachlokes, right? If you're coming
from a place where they don't do melacha
and you don't do melacha, then you're creating
machlokes, because there... there it stands out. Right.
Right. So the whole Mishnah is very hard
to understand. Meaning the Mishnah says don't change
from what's being done because of machlokes. Okay,
but I thought you also told me I
have to be machmir for... for whatever I
was machmir from beforehand. So that's that's the
issue with this Mishnah. Maybe we won't get
into exactly what this theoretical perspective would be
if you're machmir for everything. The Rishonim say
it doesn't mean what it sounds like. It
does not mean that all chumros just automatically
apply in all directions. If you look at
the Ran, source three, he says there's a
very... you have to read this Mishnah very
carefully. It means something very specific. So he
says, he quotes the whole Mishnah, jump to
the second line. peirush mishnatenu besheda'ato lachazor limekomo.
The whole Mishnah is talking specifically about a
person who plans on going back to their
original place. That's his very, very fundamental yesod.
It's not just him, other Rishonim say it
also, it's based on the Gemara. But he
says the entire Mishnah is talking about where
I'm going somewhere and I'm planning on returning
back to my original place. umishum hachi katani
haholech mimakom she'ein osin lemakom she'osin. Therefore it
says, now now he tells you how to
read the Mishnah. When I go from a
place where they don't do melacha and I
go to a place where they do do
melacha. So what do I... what's the halacha?
keivan sheda'ato lachazor notnin alav chumrei hamakom sheyatza
misham midina. Since I plan on going back
to the place where they do not do
melacha, the halacha is, this is a halacha,
he's saying midina, the actual halacha for him
is that this person has a requirement to
keep the halachos of the place which he
originally lived in and which he plans on
returning to. That's a halacha. umimakom she'osin lemakom
she'ein osin. What about the reverse? Where I
am from a place where they're more meikel,
we do melacha... and I go to a
place where they're more machmir, they don't do
melacha. af al gav de-mi-dina oseh, even though
really the halacha is you're allowed to do
melacha, you're a person from the first type
of minhag, nonetheless, keivan she-daato lachazor because you
plan on returning, afilu hachi al yeshane mipnei
ha-machlokes. The Mishna at the end tells you
when you're in Rome, act like the Romans
and be machmir. But that machmir is only
to avoid acting out, to avoid looking different
from the rest of the population. So he
adds ve-keivan de-mipnei ha-machlokes hu ve-lav mi-dina, since
this when you're in Rome and you're doing
like the Romans, that's not really the halacha
but that's just to avoid machlokes, yesh lomar
davka bifneihem hu de-metzar ha be-tzina shari. So
then the issur is only when you're in
public that you shouldn't be acting differently in
public, but when you're be-tzina, when you are
alone in your home, so you can do
what you want. So this shiur is not
about the following case, but in theory let's
just talk about an Israeli coming to Chutz
La'aretz because this is the easier case. So
what the Shulchan Aruch, the Shulchan Aruch talks
about this case explicitly. Shulchan Aruch says if
I'm an Eretz Yisrael Yid and I come
to Chutz La'aretz, so when I'm in public
because of machlokes I have to keep two
days of Yom Tov, I can't do melacha
in front of other Chutznikim, if we'll use
that word. But when I'm at my home
and no one can tell if I'm doing
melacha or not, so then I would be
allowed to go and do melacha. That's the
basic the basic halacha. Yeah, Shan. So when
you say you make it look like you're
keeping two days of Yom Tov, if you're
with somebody the whole day, they'll also realize
they're not doing the mitzvos asay which they're
not doing the day. That's a good question.
So the question was if you're with someone
the whole day, they'll be able to tell
you're not doing the mitzvos asay. I'm understanding
the issur melacha part. Right. Do they have
to do a seder? When an Israeli's in
in America, do they have to do a
seder? is basically a second seder is your
question. So good question. The answer is I
didn't look into that enough to give you
a proper answer. My guess is that we'll
just say stay in a different room and
as long as you're not publicly desecrating it's
not going to lead to machlokes, but I'm
not certain about that. But it's just one
other person. They probably know this is primarily
a larger public like mara d'asra where the
person that could be walking past and doesn't
know you from from Adam doesn't know that
you're an Israeli. Right, so how to apply
this, you know, who it applies to, your
family might be different. I don't know and
ask the people who are getting asked those
questions aren't the American poskim, they're the Israeli
poskim because the Israelis are speaking to their
their Israeli poskim. Okay, so what does that
mean practically for our American who goes to
Yisrael? Let's just any guesses just so far
what does this mean? You're an American who
goes to Yisrael, what what should the halacha
be? They only have one day. They have
to keep two days in Yisrael. Right. Okay,
so so let's what would you say when
in Rome? So that was part of it,
meaning you shouldn't do differently. If they have
a chumra, you shouldn't do differently than that
chumra which they have because it would lead
to machlokes. But when you're from the place
which is more machmir, when you're from the
place which doesn't do melacha and you're in
a place where they do do melacha, the
halacha is mi-dina, says the Ran and other
Rishonim, that you are required to keep that
which you were the place where you're from,
as long as daato lachazor. As long as
you plan on going back, so the halacha
is you're required. It's you're still a Ben
Chutz La'aretz, you're still an American, and an
American keeps American halacha. Yes, good, just before
we we get to the dissenters. So far
so good. Okay, so the big, the big
name over here is the Chacham Tzvi. Who's
the Chacham Tzvi? So his name is Rav
Tzvi Hirsch Ashkenazi. I'll tell you what I
found on Wikipedia just a little bit. He
lives in the late 1600s, early 1700s. He
has a few, more than a few, but
he has a bunch of famous teshuvos. One
of them is in this topic. He's got
a very ironic name because his name is
Rav Tzvi Ashkenazi and we call him the
Chacham Tzvi. Chacham is regular name which we
reserve for Sefardi poskim, like Chacham Ovadia. So
how did that happen? So he was a
big traveler. He ended up in, depends on
which exactly place you look, either he ended
up somewhere Constantinople or Salonika somewhere, he learned
in a Sefardi yeshiva and they really really
liked him. They started calling him the Chacham
Tzvi. So we said, you know what, let's
call him the Chacham Tzvi, and that's how
he published his teshuva sefer. The teshuvos were
the that of the Chacham Tzvi. But he
got around. He fought against the Shabtai Tzvi
movement and he was certainly he was known
for being his teshuvos are nice and easy
to read in a certain sense because he
stays to the topic. Sometimes teshuvos go all
over the place and like, oh, I actually
had a chidush so I want to tell
you something and they go off on tangents.
The Chacham Tzvi stays nice and nice and
focused. So he has he disagrees with what
you would have expected. He says as follows:
Nir'eh li ani da'ati. So he was asked
this exact same question. He says:
nireh li de-tzrichim hem le-hisnaheg be-inyanei ha-moadim ke-echad
mi-benei Eretz Yisrael ha-toshavim, those who actually live
there. ve-ein ze bichlal chomrei makom she-yatza mi-sham,
and don't worry that this is part of
the rule that you have to follow the
minhagim of your original place. Why? So he
has this very very interesting idea. He says:
she-ilu hayu kol anshei ha-makom she-yatzu mi-sham kan
bi-keviyusa Let’s say the entire, I don’t know,
the entire Washington Heights community were to uproot
itself and move to Israel. So you’re from
a Washington Heights community, you’re from an American
community, and you as a whole community were
to uproot yourself and move to Israel. So
what would they do? pshita she’asurim hayu la’asot
yoter miyom echad. They can’t start keeping to
do, they can’t continue doing two days if
they uproot themselves and move to Eretz Yisroel
mishum bal tosif. Says it’ll be a problem
bal tosif. In Israel, you have a mitzvah
to keep only one day. If you were
to, the whole community were to move to
Eretz Yisroel, so of course they moved, so
they have to keep one day, they can’t
keep two days. sheharei hayoshev bishmini basukkot lokei.
Okay, he brings proofs to the idea of
bal tosif ve’khen bepesach ushavuot ha’osei yom echad
mo’ed yoter min hamitzvah over al bal tosif.
So very, very interesting idea. v’lo amru notnin
alav chumrei makom sheyatza misham. When does this
whole rule apply that you have to keep
your original minhagim? ela bechumrah sheshar bnei hamakom
sheyatza ze misham nohagim chumratam bemakom hanohagim kulam.
Only if were your whole community to uproot
itself and move to the second place where
you’re visiting, you’d be able to continue keeping
that minhag. So like erev Pesach. So if
you had a minhag to not work on
erev Pesach and you lived in Salonica and
you moved to Washington Heights, you could keep
doing that minhag. There’s nothing wrong with not
doing melacha on erev Pesach. But if you
live in Washington Heights and you move as
a community to Eretz Yisroel, you are not
allowed to keep two days of Yom Tov.
You have to keep one day of Yom
Tov. He has a line at the end
which I think is really what he’s saying
in a simpler way. What he says at
the end is just the bolded last line.
keivan shehamakom goreim. At the end of the
day, this is not just a minhag which
is up to oh, what was my minhag,
what was your minhag. This is based on
the place. The place is if you’re in
Israel, so you keep one day. If you’re
in chutz la’aretz, chutz la’aretz people keep two
days. So it’s not shayakh to the general
rule of keep the minhagim of from where
you came from, because those minhagim are specific
to places by definition, not just by happenstance.
That’s that’s his first main argument. And then
he has a second argument. His second argument’s
very hard to understand. He says, excuse me,
he says, ve-af, if you jump to the
end of the to the end of the
big bold, ve-af d’shalchu mitam hizaharu beminhag avoteichem.
Ay, didn’t they say in the Gemara you
have to keep to your minhagim? dilma gazru
shmada ve-ati l’kalkulei. Well, isn’t the whole concern
that someone’s going to have a shmad and
you’re not going to be able to keep
the mitzvot and you’re going to lose the
calendar? hakha kalkalah gufah lo shayakha ela keshehem
bimkomam bechutz la’aretz. When would you ever have
a problem of this shmad of losing the
calendar? If you’re in chutz la’aretz. aval biheyotam
be’eretz yisroel lo shayakh. If everyone were to
get up and move to Eretz Yisroel and
there were a shmad, so he says it’s
not shayakh that you’d have such a problem
that people would lose the calendar. He doesn’t
explain why that is. He just says if
you were to move to Israel, what, you
think a shmad would really cause problems? It
can’t be. Wait, but they don’t say in
Israel like because if he said that then
he would have said in Israel too they
should be keeping two days. Right, so we
don’t say in Israel keep two days because
that wasn’t the minhag of avoteihem. Meaning there’s
two parts here. The first part is keep
your minhag which was in chutz la’aretz they
would keep two days and why are we
telling you to keep that minhag because it
could lead to a problem down the line.
But in Israel they never even made that
takanah because they were always keeping one day,
so they didn’t feel the need to force
the two days upon them. So already his
son Rabbi Yaakov Emden says I’m not exactly
sure why he thinks that the that the
shmad couldn’t be an issue in Eretz Yisroel,
but okay, at least that first, that first
sevara is very interesting that it’s a makom
goreim, it’s a minhag which is specifically dependent
on a place. So maybe this whole rule
doesn’t apply. If you look, can I just
say this is also going back to what
you were saying before about keeping the population
of Jews in other places. I mean, we
don’t look at it from Europe more or
less because there’s such a huge community, but
a Jewish community that’s very small off in
chutz la’aretz and to find a minyan is
difficult and if you go anywhere like outside
of a city, the community’s so much smaller
so shmad is much easier. Okay,
okay, so Yosef saying that maybe what he
meant is that the communities in Israel were
historically larger and it would be harder for
them all to lose. I think the Ramban
in one of his letters talks about how
like he couldn’t find a minyan except for
in Yerushalayim. Like there wasn’t, wasn’t always the
case that there were such large Jewish communities
in in Israel. But also something else, it
was because Yerushalayim at the time of the
Ramban was sacked by Mongols and all the
Jews either fled or were killed. Right, but
I’m saying you could have, you could have
something like that again if there was a
shmad, so they they could do the same
thing. Yeah, but it’s not a it’s not
a shmad. shmad means that they try to
uproot. Right, right. shmad regularly is more of
an attacking our mitzvot more than the people.
I hear what you’re saying. Okay, so maybe
maybe that’s what what’s going on. If you
look the Shulchan Aruch HaRav, the Ba’al HaTanya,
the first Lubavitcher Rebbe, so he he was
he thought the Chacham Tzvi was correct. He
says bnei chutz la’aretz sheba’u l’eretz yisroel. If
you have bnei chutz la’aretz who come to
Eretz Yisroel, af al pi sheda’atam lachazor, even
though you plan on returning back home, ein
osin ela yom echad k’vnei eretz yisroel. Israel.
You should just do like the bnei eretz
yisrael vyesh cholkin. He says, yes, some people
disagree, but he says, says the Shulchan Aruch
Harav that the standard halacha he thinks should
be like the chacham tzvi. Okay. So that's,
that's where the one day opinion comes from.
So what's, what's the problem with the one
day opinion? So the problem is that it
went against probably a thousand years of minhag.
If you look at the Avkat Rochel, if
you turn the page, so again, the chacham
tzvi was written, was published at the beginning
of the 1700s. The Avkat Rochel is written
by, is the teshuva sefer of the Beis
Yosef. So Beis Yosef he writes the Shulchan
Aruch, he writes the Kesef Mishneh. He also
has this teshuva sefer which doesn't get quite
as much press, the Avkat Rochel, but he
was asked this same question. The Avkat Rochel's
interesting though because it wasn't published until 200
years after the Beis Yosef died. We had
it in parts and we had a bunch
of scattered teshuvos, some people published these and
some published those, and someone finally put it
together 200 years later called the Avkat Rochel.
So the chacham tzvi did not have this
teshuva most likely in front of him when
he wrote his teshuva, but the Beis Yosef
writes as follows. He says in, he's got
strong language here. He says Teshuva. Davar pashut
hu dechol shedaato lachazor noheg kemakom sheyatza misham.
Anytime you're planning on returning somewhere, you have
to keep the chumros of the place from
which you left afilu lehakel. That would be
true even lekula ubilvad shelo yaase bifnei bnei
hamakom. Okay, he goes through the whole thing.
I'm actually going to skip until the, after
the ellipses, four lines from the bottom v'chen
maasim bechol yom. He says this happens all
the time. People come to Eretz Yisrael. You
have to remember the Beis Yosef, so he
ends up in Tzfat. So v'chen maasim bechol
yom bechol shana v'shana olim lishlosh regalim mchutz
l'aretz to l'aretz. Every one of the three
regalim we have people coming up from chutz
l'aretz to Eretz Yisrael v'osim yom sheni shel
galuyos ketikuno u'chemishpato bechutz l'aretz. They do the
whole two days of Yom Tov like you're
supposed to in chutz l'aretz v'lo od ela
shemitkabtzim minyan mibnei chutz l'aretz and goes into
exactly how you do a minyan and one
thing which he's dealing with over there is
that we said you should try and avoid
machlokes, so he's trying to figure out so
then how come we have public minyanim in
Eretz Yisrael to do Yom Tov Sheni minyanim.
You're they're doing they're acting like Yom Tov
publicly in a certain sense. He's bothered by
that, but you know, we can hold off
on the minyan question for right now. So
the Beis Yosef says the, again Beis Yosef
is a hundred years at least earlier than
the chacham tzvi. He says the minhag everyone
was keeping two days. Rav Ovadia, I didn't
give you the actual quotes, but Rav Ovadia
quotes that in the Teshuvos Geonei Mizrach u-Maarav
and the Maaseh HaGeonim, I think that these
are Geonim sefarim, I don't know if they
were found in the Cairo Geniza, but Rav
Ovadia Yosef knew literally everything. So if, if
anyone ever wrote it, he knows it. So
in the 900s already we have these teshuvos
from the Geonim and the Geonim teshuvos says
Rav Ovadia also say you keep two days.
That's what we're all doing. So this standard,
standard psak is to keep two days. There's
the chacham tzvi, there's this Baal HaTanya the
Shulchan Aruch Harav, there's a Sholom Meshiv who
say you keep one day. But the psak
going back at least a thousand years we
know is that people were keeping two days.
The author of the Beis Yosef, the author
of the Shulchan Aruch says in his teshuva
you keep two days. And I'll just tell
you a short list of, before I get
the short list or I'll say the short
list now anyways, short list of contemporary poskim
who say you keep two days is just
about anyone who ever, who you might have
probably heard of nowadays. So the Mishna Berura
first of all is clear that that's what
you do. If you look in source seven
Uben chutz laretz sheba leretz yisrael im daato
lachazor limkomo tzarich laasos shnei yamim tovim. You
have to keep two days of Yom Tov.
Achen im daato shelo lachazor limkomo leolam yitnaheg
kivnei eretz yisrael uchmo shemevoar. If you plan
on staying there, so then you start acting
like the bnei eretz yisrael. So besides for
the Mishna Berura, I'll just tell you Rav
Moshe Feinstein, Rav Shlomo Zalman Auerbach, the Minchas
Yitzchak, Rav Elyashiv, Rav Wosner, and Rav Ovadia.
They all pasken in a stam case, but
we're going to have to talk about in
a moment what it means that I plan
on returning or don't plan on returning. If
I have nothing going for me in terms
of living in Eretz Yisrael, I am quite
certain I am coming back home after this
chag and let's say other chaggim I'm not
planning on being there for all three regalim.
We'll talk about that shortly. So then almost
all contemporary poskim say you keep two days
of Yom Tov. That's that's just the, yeah.
Isn't that why Chabad says you only keep
one day is because they hold that in
Eretz Yisrael you're not allowed... Also Rav Ovadia
said you're going to like find out. Yeah,
so we'll get to Rav Ovadia shortly. Chabad
is the exception. Chabad is the exception because
of this Shulchan Aruch Harav. Shulchan Aruch Harav
is the big posek for Chabad. The Shulchan
Aruch Harav, he writes also elsewhere that like
there's this idea which I didn't understand of
kedusha, that you know there's a certain like
the place has a certain kedusha which is
only fit for one day, that's Eretz Yisrael,
and outside there's the kedusha needs to be
spread out more. So it's more like about
where you are and the kedusha inherently has
to be one day or two days. So
the Shulchan Aruch Harav, if you're if you're
Chabad, if you have strong Chabad roots or
strong Chabad connections, it makes a lot of
sense, you know I think probably the standard
psak is one day if you have a
Chabad posek, you know ask them to, to.
confirm them. But the vast majority of Poskim
say in a normal case, I confirmed with
Rabbi Taubes, he says the same. Rabbi Taubes
says two days to anyone who asks him
a Stam Shayla. We're going to get again
to all the exceptions, there are a lot
of exceptions. But, yeah. Is there an issue,
is it specifically this is a common question,
of if you're only going for half of
Pesach? Like the first half? Yeah. Like if
you're only there for one, is there an
issue of like keeping one day, but then
like or some or the other way around,
but then like eating Chametz on the last
day if you had two Sedarim or something
like that? Right. Right. So how many Sedarim
do you do? So I haven't seen anyone
saying like there's a Tarti Desatri issue. Like
if you, if you're a Chabad person, whatever,
you follow the Chacham Tzevi and you keep
one day the first days. That's just because
when I'm in Israel, so I only keep
one day. But keep then I leave Eretz
Yisrael, I'm keeping two days. So that would,
I don't think that would be unreasonable. Yeah.
We're talking just practical. I know someone, I'm
not gonna say who, who is Moroccan Israeli
but lives here. So he's been living here
many years. So the first days of Pesach
he's going to be here. He has a
daughter though who made Aliyah who lives in
Israel, who's getting married in Israel and wants
to do a Mimouna. The wedding's going to
be the Mimouna which is the day after
Pesach. So the Mimouna is. So he's going
to Israel Chol HaMoed for the last part
of Pesach and the wedding will be what
would be in Chutz La'Aretz the eighth day
of Pesach. So he's going to be in
Israel for his daughter's wedding which will be
a Mimouna. Complicated. Complicated.
I'll let him deal with that Shayla. What?
I'll let him deal with that Shayla. He's
saying what he's doing though is he's not
keep, you know, he's going to be here
the first days and keep two days. He
lives here usually, goes to Israel via aliyah
whatever, but like keeps two days, but the
last days his daughter's getting married on, you
know, Mimouna day. And I think he's not
keep, he said he's not keeping the last
day of Pesach as Pesach. Okay, so again,
I'm not I'm my goal here is not
to tell you about what anyone else is
doing. I'm just telling you what I've seen
and I'd say what I'd say the standard
approach to this topic is. So let me
just there's a few other points. So what
is the response to the Chacham Tzevi? So
Rav Shlomo Zalman Auerbach and others just explain
it's not necessarily true that this rule of
Chumrei Makom Sheyatza Misham that you are basically
where you return to is dependent on whether
it's a Minhag which is dependent on place
or not. Meaning which is specific to Eretz
Yisrael. As long as you are in America
at the end of the day, you keep
the American Shulkhan Arukh and if you are
Israeli at the end of the day, you
keep the Israeli Shulkhan Arukh. Has anyone ever
heard of one and a half days before?
Yeah. Yeah. Everyone's heard of one and a
half days. I hadn't heard of one and
a half days until I went to HaKotel.
That's the first time I ever heard of
it, my Yeshiva for my first year in
Israel. So what is one and a half
days? So one, the second Gemara sounded a
little bit like. Yes. Yes. So the Gemara
sounded like this idea. One what what is
one and a half days? One and a
half days says, you know what, really either
we should be keeping two days or one
day, whichever side you take, but I'm worried
about the other opinion. So I'm going to
try and be Machmir for every single thing
that I can do as if it were
both two days and one day at the
same time. So what does that end up
being? It ends up being a little miserable
in my experience. But you end up not
doing any Melakha, so you can't you can't
like do anything, you know, with all which
all the Israelis are doing. But you also
depending on how you Pasken, depending on whether
you think it's you're really two days is
what you should be keeping or really one
day you should be keeping, but you're going
to let's say you're a man you'll put
on Tefillin and maybe you make a Bracha
maybe you don't make a Bracha depending on
on the case. Or you'll maybe make a
Seder without Brachot, with Brachot, without without Brachot
etc. You'll Daven, how you'll Daven will depend
on exactly where you end on that question.
But you basically try and be Machmir for
everything in all directions as much as possible.
Now why why did that come about? So
the answer is that a lot of Poskim
were very taken by the Chacham Tzevi argument.
They thought, you know, I know it's against
all the Poskim, all the Poskim basically don't
accept, again, most most of the Poskim don't
accept the Chacham Tzevi. But his argument's very
strong. This is something which is dependent on
the place. If it's something which is dependent
on the place, so they're they're at least
saying maybe we should be Machmir for that
idea. There's actually another point which a lot
of them bring up. What were they doing,
let's let's say you were an American who
made Aliyah L'Regel in the times of the
Beit HaMikdash. So how many days did you
keep? You presumably kept one. Meaning there's there
might even be Gemaras I saw someone quoting.
I didn't I they didn't have a source
but they said online that Gemaras say so
I don't know if that's true or not.
But but if you made Aliyah L'Regel, so
you're in Eretz Yisrael, there's no reason for
you to be keeping two. It wasn't like
a Minhag they had. Just when they weren't
sure if it was Yom Tov or not.
So when they came to when they didn't
know they'd keep two days M'Safek and when
they were in Eretz Yisrael, so they'd keep
one day. So if the whole goal is
really Hizaharu Beminhag Avoteichem Beyadeichem, keep the Minhag
of your parents of your grandparents, so how
can it be that you're expecting me to
be more Machmir than my grandparents were when
I was in Israel? It's a very strong
argument. Yeah. There's one exception though, meaning it
sounds like a very strong argument, there's one
very very big exception to the rule of
that we're just copying what our avos did.
There's one time where our avos were certainly
keeping one day, and we keep two days
in Chutz La'aretz. Anyone know? This is like
a sixty thousand dollar question. So Shavuos. Shavuos
in the Torah is always forty-nine days after
we count the Omer and then we have
we have Shavuos. So as long as you
would know what the first day of Nisan
was, so then you're going to be able
to figure out when Shavuos is as long
as by the time Shavuos comes you know
when the first day of Nisan is. Because
when if once you figure out the first
day of Nisan, you'll figure out the first
day of Pesach, and then fifty days later
is going to be Shavuos no matter what.
Outside of it didn't take sixty days to
go in and get the news out to
maybe in America it would have, but but
in Bavel and other areas, they would have
actually known when Shavuos was almost definitely and
they were keeping one day almost always. When
they made this takkanah keep two days, so
they just said you know what, let's make
Shavuos like Pesach and like Sukkos, let's not
confuse everyone. They made it two days even
though that wasn't what the actual minhag of
our forefathers was. So it's not, you know,
this argument is not ironclad that we should
just be keeping what our avos did. There's
a little bit of lo palug, there's a
little bit of you know kind of getting
out the wrinkles in in how it's done.
So but how can you say like keep
two days for Pesach and Sukkos but only
one day for Shavuos? No, so I have
not seen any poskim say keep two days
of X and only one day of Shavuos
though, even though you know you could have
you could have heard such such an argument.
So I'll tell you there were poskim... But
which day is Rosh Chodesh Nisan then you
also would know which day is Pesach so
you also... No but I'm saying you would
figure out when Rosh Chodesh Nisan was let's
say thirty days later. Let's say by Iyar,
thirty days... so Pesach has already passed, and
now I figure out when the first day
of Nisan was, the word gets to me
that when the first day of Nisan was.
So I've already kept two days of Pesach
because it didn't get to me in time,
it didn't get to me within fifteen days,
but it got to me within sixty days,
whatever it was, so so that that would
be all that they need. You're saying a
minhag of keeping the minhag you're saying. No,
the first source of the minhag of the
poskim... Oh yeah yeah yeah yeah, making trouble,
making trouble. Right, right, one hundred percent. So
I'll just tell you some poskim who held
this way. Rav Shmuel Salant held this way,
Rav Kook held this way, and Rav Soloveitchik,
so he also would tell talmidim to be
machmir for one and a half days. He
personally never had to, because the only time
he ever went to Eretz Yisrael he went
to Eretz Yisrael for only one regel, I
forget I think it was Shavuos or whatever
it was, and the way it worked out
was that Friday was the first day of
yom tov, and then what would have been
the second day of yom tov was Shabbos.
So no one was keeping melacha was doing
melacha. Rav Soloveitchik. So he didn't have to
daven? Say again? So he didn't have to
daven? Right, so the way that the Rav
was told to do it was to keep
it like to daven like a ben Eretz
Yisrael, to keep it like the chachamim of
Sefad in terms of davening. So in Israel
they were also davening that way. So it
ended up being that he didn't have to
take a stand on it personally, but that's
what he would apparently tell his talmidim. So
Rav Shechter writes and Rav Willig writes similarly
that like if you're you know if you
follow all of the Rav psakim, so nice
to keep one point five days. It's very
very hard. I'll tell you my... I only
tried it once in Hakotel and it was
I was flipping... I must have been mechalel
yom tov sheini so many times just because
you're like you're just very very confused because
you're treating it as a chol day but
a yom tov day. It's really it's not
fun at all. What does mechalel mean in
that context? melacha? Exactly. You treat it like
chol and then some people say you shouldn't
be wearing your yom tov bigadim if you
think it's really not yom tov, so you're
wearing like your chol clothes. It's like it's
a little bit of a headache. If someone's
really you know wants a challenge, that's an
opinion which you might want to follow. If
you don't want a challenge, so Rav Neuberger
said he used to tell people to do
this and then he got so much response
back that it just it wasn't working. So
he tells people to do two days. Rav
Willig says the same thing. And okay fine.
So so that's all about a stam visitor.
I guess we'll get to what are the
exceptions. So again if you are planning on
living there, so it's open and shut no
question, you're an Israeli now. If I the
moment I make my decision, I get off
the plane, the Nefesh B'Nefesh plane on the
day before Pesach, I'm keeping one day now.
Not a question. There was someone from Belgium
who he had a small group of two-day
and then there was someone from Belgium who
finished up her aliyah paperwork like erev yom
tov. So she like left our second day
of yom tov group on erev yom tov.
That's awesome. Okay. So if you get your
aliyah papers in right before yom tov, so
then then you are good to go. So
what if I'm planning on living there for
I don't know a year, two years, five
years, I have a job with a set
amount of time and then after that I
have no plan. So how exactly long does
it last? So this is the poskim debate
exactly how long, but I think that the
majority view is that of the Aruch HaShulchan,
a lot of poskim the Tzitz Eliezer... A
lot of poskim, the Tzitz Eliezer, Avnei Nezer,
Shevet HaLevi, they all say the same idea:
V'chen yeira'eh li d'afilu ba levado im ein
da'ato lachazor ad achar shanah mikri ein da'ato
lachazor. If you really don't plan on even
getting back on a plane until for one
year and this is talking about when you're
not relying on your parents back home or
something like that, but if you're an independent
person and you plan on living in Israel
for a year, you're not coming back for
a year, so that's good enough says the
Aruch HaShulchan, you are now an Israeli. Okay,
so these are, in a certain sense, the
simpler cases. Anyone ever hear of the three
regalim heter? Right, so this I think is
a famous one, I think I grew up
with this one. This is Rav Shlomo Zalman
Auerbach's big chiddush. Rav Shlomo Zalman Auerbach says
that if you have you know you'll be
in Israel for all three regalim, so this
is a Yom Tov halacha. This whole halacha
is a Yom Tov halacha. With respect to
Yom Tov then, you are an Israeli for
the whole year basically. So it's a very
interesting, it's a little counterintuitive. Does it matter
where it starts? Say again. Does it matter
where it starts? Right, so let's read, I'm
not sure if it's so clear if it
matters when it starts: Nireh l'aniyut da'ati d'yeish
ladun bemi sheyeish lo dirah kevuah b'Eretz Yisrael
v'kavu atzmam lihyot tamid b'diratam sheb'Eretz Yisrael yachad
im ishto u'vnei beito b'chol shloshet haregalim. So
maybe he means that you always do that,
this is the plan for the next ten
years, I'm not sure, he's not so clear.
He says you plan on spending the shalosh
regalim in Eretz Yisrael. V'af sherov hashanah hem
b'Chutz La'aretz, you're spending all the rest of
the time b'Chutz La'aretz, m'kol makom l'inyan Yom
Tov Sheini keivan shehahevdel bein Eretz Yisrael l'Chutz
La'aretz shayach rak b'gimmel regalim. Since this whole
distinction is only relevant for the three regalim,
nireh l'aniyut da'ati d'ein aleihem shem Bnei Chutz
La'aretz b'yachas l'Yom Tov Sheini. We look at
you as an Israeli with respect to Yom
Tov because with respect to Yom Tov you
are always an Israeli. So I think sometimes
you get asked this shaila or you hear
about this shaila. People think oh I'm keeping
Sukkot and Pesach in Israel so I'm now
a Ben Eretz Yisrael according to this Minchat
Shlomo. So the problem is you also have
to be there for Shavuot. Rav Shlomo Zalman
Auerbach never said if you're there for two
out of three that that's going to be
good enough. This alone is a big chiddush,
but two out of three, which I think
a lot of people think is good enough,
I don't know too many people who fly
back also for Shavuot, maybe people do, but
for the most part I don't know how
often this comes up practically. Where did he
get such a svara? This is like I
don't know, it's a little surprising, I'm there
for all the yamim tovim so now I'm
an Israeli. So he says I know that
what I'm saying is a big chiddush, like
I wouldn't have been so comfortable saying it.
He says but at the end of the
day jump to the bold: m'kol makom b'tzeruf
im shitat haChacham Tzvi asher devarav hem divrei
svara. Since the Chacham Tzvi also thinks you'll
always keep one day even without the three
yamim tovim and what he's saying makes a
lot of sense, so you put that together
with this svara and he says now I'm
comfortable being meikel. This is a theme throughout
a lot of teshuvot and again if you
have any specific situations you should ask a
rabbi. But many many poskim say well if
we can just push you a little bit
more into the Eretz Yisrael category, the Chacham
Tzvi had a nice argument, that should be
enough to get you into the Eretz Yisrael
box even though they wouldn't necessarily be comfortable
based on that svara alone. We mentioned Rav
Ovadia, I'll summarize him over here. Rav Ovadia
has a fascinating idea. He says, and this
is I think what Sefardim do follow l'ma'aseh,
although they should ask their rabbis. Let's say
he's talking about a male, so he's talking
about a bachur, you're in yeshiva and we
ask the bachur if you were to find
a nice Israeli girl, yeah you're currently dependent
on your parents, but you find a nice
Israeli girl and the way he puts it
is, and she'd give you a really big
dowry so that you could survive in Eretz
Yisrael, would you stay? And if his answer
is yes, so he says that's good enough.
Again with the Chacham Tzvi enough that we
can consider it's possible that you'd be a
Ben Eretz Yisrael. That's enough that as long
as you could in theory stay here, that
would be good enough. Then he has this
great line at the end, he says what
if, we won't read it inside, but you
can read it yourselves. He says what if
you say no, no I wouldn't, my parents
would be so upset? So what you should
do then is you should tell him you
know living in Eretz Yisrael is a mitzvah,
the halacha is Pru u'Rvu is a mitzvah
and the halacha is if your parents ever
try and tell you to do something against
a mitzvah, the real halacha is you shouldn't
listen to your parents. So again if there's
a l'ma'aseh shaila someone should ask a rabbi
instead of acting based on this one statement.
So he says you should try and convince
him really the halacha is you should stay
in Eretz Yisrael if you find such a
wonderful young woman. So if he says I
guess you know if you put it that
way maybe I would stay, so he says
that would be good enough to go and
consider you a Ben Eretz Yisrael. So if
I have someone set up on a shidduch
date who are in Israel that means I
think keep one day and go on there
right? So I'm not posek the shaila, you
would have to ask whoever you normally ask
your shailot to. Not again, this is Rav
Ovadia's big chiddush. I'm not sure everyone is,
is the Israeli staying in Israel is the
question. But that's according to Rav Ovadia the
answer would be yes. If you're going on
a shidduch date in Israel and that person
is planning on staying in Israel no matter
what and you would join them, so then
Rav Ovadia at least would be meikel that
you could keep one day. Have to make
sure the dates don't end before Pesach then,
but. Wait, that's yours right now. Oh, sorry.
Okay, so we can figure out the specific
application. I'll just tell you one thing which,
yeah, when I was at Nishmat, the story
there was that the rabbi there
would do the Rav Ovadia thing of like
if you meet a guy that you'd stay,
and his story is that there was like
one year that there was someone who wanted
to do like Magen David Adom training on
what would have been Yom Tov Sheni, so
like they really wanted to find the Hetter
so they could go and do the Magen
David Adom training, and she's like, no, I
would go back, and he's like, no, maybe
you'd stay, so finally she's like, okay, fine,
I'll stay. So he's like, okay, great, you
can keep only one day, and she ended
up marrying the instructor of the Magen David
Adom training. Wow, she ended up marrying the
trainer she got on Yom Tov Sheni, that's
incredible. That's a great story. That's a great
story. I'll tell you one Hetter which I
just there's it's against an explicit Rav Moshe
Feinstein. Some people I've heard are Meikal as
long as you have an apartment. If you
have an apartment in Eretz Yisrael, that's that's
enough. So Moshe writes explicitly that nowadays that
means nothing. You can have an apartment in
a whole bunch of places, you would fly
back. Back in the day, could be that
having an apartment, if you had a home
there, so that would mean you stay, but
he says that's that's not really such a
such a real big Inyan. Rav Neuburger, the
way Rav Neuburger put it is that unfortunately
in this area whenever someone somewhere says something,
so everyone else says, oh, so that must
be the Halakha as long as it's Meikal.
So that's that's unfortunate. Some people are following
doing one day I think Shelo Kedin and
you should ask your local rabbi. I'll just
end by saying that sometimes we have this
tension in Chutz La'aretz because people don't really
like this whole two-day Yom Tov thing, they
all want to do the one day and
especially three-day Yom Tov. So one of my
Rabbanim says we should start calling it three
days of Kedusha instead of three days of
Yom Tov, like you should should try and
like we got to change the the bad
rap that three days of Yom Tov has.
Yom Tov is a wonderful thing, we should
really embrace it. So I don't know, maybe
that you know fits for some people and
just happens to not fit so well for
me. The other approach which I once heard
from Rav Wosner is, no, it's okay for
it to be uncomfortable. It's good that you
don't enjoy three days Yom Tov. The goal
in the Torah HaKadosh Baruch Hu wants everyone
in Eretz Yisrael and especially right now we're
trying to keep the Eretz Yisrael everyone in
Eretz Yisrael in our mind. If you're keeping
Yom Tov Sheni even while you're there in
Eretz Yisrael, reminder to yourself you know the
real place where we are supposed to be
you know before Biat Goel and certainly once
Biat Goel Moshiach, so then we should be
in Eretz Yisrael and if we're a little
uncomfortable, so it's a good reminder that hopefully
one day we'll all end up there Be'karov.
Okay, everyone should have a fantastic